GREG BRAIL: Hi I'm
Greg Brail from Google.
I want to talk today about APIs.
In particular, about
how companies are using
APIs to deliver new experiences
for their customers,
whether those our business
customers or ordinary people,
and how you can actually
do that in your business.
There are going to be
three parts to this talk.
We're going to start with an
update about some ways in which
people are using APIs today.
Some ways in which
companies are using
APIs to deliver new digital
experiences and in some cases,
even new business to
business experiences.
We're also going to talk about
how you can govern and manage
those APIs through
the whole lifecycle,
so any APIs create can actually
be useful and productive
and allow all sorts of new
technologies to be created.
And finally, I want to
talk about implementation
strategies.
What is API
management, how does it
fit in, how do you actually
fit an API or an API program
into today's kinds of
digital architecture.
First, however, we want
to talk a little bit
about what's important on
our mind today and some
of the things that
we're thinking
about a lot in today's world.
First of all, we're thinking
a lot about health care.
We're thinking
about being healthy.
We're thinking about keeping
our families healthy.
We're thinking about how we're
going to get health care,
how are we going to
visit the doctor.
Are we going to do a video
visit, an actual visit.
How are we going to
pay for the doctor.
What's the status
of our insurance.
These are all the
kinds of things
that are on our mind today.
We're actually going
to talk about food.
We all have to eat,
and nowadays, we
find ourselves asking
questions like,
where's dinner coming from?
Are we going to cook it?
Are we getting grocery delivery?
Are we going to
the grocery store?
Are we ordering our food?
Are we calling on a?
Phone are we using an app?
Are we using a delivery service?
There are more options than
there have ever been before
and a of those options
are driven by APIs.
And finally, we want to talk
about how we get the things we
need to run our household.
How do we get those
necessities of daily life,
where are we going to find them,
are there enough in the store.
Can we order them online?
Do we need to have
them delivered?
Do we need to go to
the store and get them?
These are all the
kinds of questions
that people are asking.
Retail is one of those
industries that's
been going through a digital
transformation for a long time
now.
And APIs are an important
part of what they do, as well.
So let me talk about three
companies who are actually
in these three particular areas
and some innovative things
that they're doing with APIs.
The first company is
Change Health Care.
Change Health Care is not
a health care provider
or a hospital,
conglomerate, or a doctor.
They're a service provider
to all those people.
In particular, they
offer something
that they call the
API and Services
Connection for
Health Care, which
is just what it sounds like.
It's a set of APIs that these
different kinds of health care
providers can use in order
to deliver things like health
eligibility calculations.
Patients' responsibility
calculations,
so when you're going
to go to the doctor,
you can have some
idea how much you'll
have to pay out of pocket versus
how much insurance will cover.
So basically, they're
a service provider
for all these health
care companies
that want to offer a better
digital patient experience.
And they're using APIs
for one of the things
that we've talked
about APIs being useful
for for many years, which is to
allow third party innovation.
They provide a set of services.
And their customers can
then build on those services
to deliver innovative technology
for all of their consumers.
Now if we move on
to food, one company
that's no stranger to a
digital experiences Pizza Hut.
Pizza Hut now has an app
called the pizza tracker.
And the pizza tracker
literally lets
you keep track of your pizza.
And believe it or not,
on the Super Bowl,
which is the American
football championship, which
is a big event in America,
a lot of people want pizza.
And when they order that pizza,
they want to know where it is.
So Pizza Hut has to not only
deliver these new digital
experiences-- because people
don't just want to call
the local pizza place and have
someone mumble back to them
and hope that their pizza
is going to arrive in time
for the kickoff--
they want to know
that they're going
to get the exact pizza they
ordered, when they ordered it,
when they need it.
So for that, this pizza tracker
is a new digital experience
they've created.
And they've built it on
top of a layer of APIs
that connects to systems
that they already
had within the business
for tackling these things.
In addition, of
course, they have
to deal with these
huge traffic spikes.
The Super Bowl is
probably the biggest one
they've had to
deal with to date.
So they take advantage of all
the things underneath the API
layer and like auto scaling,
Google Kubernetes Engine,
and other technologies
like that,
so that when that demand
spikes, their IT systems
don't struggle,
and you don't give
the customers a bad experience.
But then you give
them a good experience
of giving them a
responsive app that
lets them track a very important
thing that's on their way
to their house to keep
their friends happy and fed.
And finally, we'll
talk about retail.
Retail Has been doing digital
things for a long time.
But there are a lot of new
things that are happening.
Conrad Electronic
is one example--
they're actually in Germany.
And one of the things they did
is they took a lot of the data
from their existing
legacy data warehouse
and moved it into BigQuery.
This is not a
BigQuery presentation.
There are some
great ones at NEXT
I'm sure you can listen to.
But one of the things
they did with BigQuery
then was give
access to those data
warehouse items via an API.
By doing that, now
their B2B customers
can now use those APIs
on top of BigQuery
to have more timely
and more accurate
information about
Conrad's offerings
and even their inventory
than they could have before,
because they gave him
a channel for getting
that information that's
much easier for developers
to consume.
In addition-- and we'll talk a
little bit about this pattern,
as well--
once they had those
APIs, they could
build a new in-store tool.
And that in-store
tool is something
that their associates
in the store
can use in order to
help customers better
understand what's in
stock, what the price is.
And now when you
come to the store,
the people who work in
the store with that tool
are better informed than
they ever were before,
resulting in a better customer
experience, which I imagine
means more people
want to shop there.
So that's a really
cool example of using
an API for multiple
contexts, both for B2B,
as well as to improve
the way things
work internally, and improve
their own customer experience.
So that's a little bit
about how APIs are being
used by all kinds of companies.
And they all have APIs
at the core, really.
And what we found is that--
I've been talking about APIs
on and off since about 2009.
It began as something
that people were not sure
why we were talking
about it-- like, really,
do we really want to offer
these external services?
And now, they've
really become the way
that industries of
all types communicate.
And those examples are just
some of the examples of the way
that people are doing
things like building
new mobile
applications, building
other kinds of
digital applications,
and building business to
business services based
on APIs.
But of course, once you build
the API, you have to govern it.
You have to keep
track of it, and you
have to make that API useful.
And that's really where a lot of
the challenge of API management
comes in.
Whenever we talk
about APIs at Google,
we almost always start
with this little chart,
we see here, which we call
the digital value chain.
And there are a couple of
important things about this.
One important
thing is, of course
I mentioned, is the technology.
After all, an API is
a bit of technology
that sits in between
the back end and an app.
It's literally the
connection between the app
and the backend.
But an equally important
part of this value chain,
maybe even more important,
is the connection
between the people.
And the connection that we're
especially interested in when
we talk about APIs
is that connection
between the developer who
uses the API and the API team
or the people who create the
API or manage or govern or even
are sometimes called the
product managers of the API.
Because making an API
successful is more than just
sticking something on the
internet with an endpoint
and telling people to use it.
It includes all kinds of
aspects that a product manager
has to consider when they want
to make the API be useful.
The interesting thing about
this digital value chain
is it also lets us focus on
of where the real value is.
So as technologists,
we always want
to start with the
backend stuff--
stuff we understand.
We have a legacy
system that keeps
track of our inventory for us.
Let's expose it as an API.
What does the API look like?
Well, it looks like
our back end system.
How do you use it?
I don't know, do you know
our back end system--
that's how you use it.
That's not really
always the best
way to make some
technology useful
outside the organization, but
it's often where we start.
But it's not always
the most effective way.
What about the developers?
How are they going to use
those APIs effectively?
What about the actual customer?
Does the API do what they need.
So it makes sense in
another perspective,
often, to talk about an
outside-in perspective,
starting with really, what
do the customers want.
If it's a business
to consumer aspect,
you have product
managers, you have
people in the
organization who probably
have all sorts of great
ideas for new services
they could offer
to their customers.
Going back to that Pizza
Hut pizza tracker app--
someone within Pizza Hut had
an idea to build that app.
They had to come to
a technology team
and say, how are we
going to build that?
Where's the information
that we need to build that?
Well, it may be locked inside
legacy systems in your company.
And it may require some
new APIs to expose it.
As another example, you
might want to do business
to business like Conrad did.
You might want to
actually make APIs
that your large
partners can use to have
a more efficient relationship
with you, which we
hope will drive more business.
That might drive a
different kind of API.
There might not only be a
different set of requirements
for what the API does, but there
could be different requirements
for the technology.
Maybe security has
to work differently.
Maybe the data has
got to be presented
in a different format.
These are all questions that
a really effective API team
probably ought to be
asking when they start
to do something with APIs.
So a great example of how to
apply this digital value chain
is to start with a
real actionable project
and then move on in order.
We did a webinar
recently with MTN,
which is a multinational
telco located in Africa.
And they've embraced APIs.
And I think they
have a great example
for how you can actually
use this digital value
chain in production.
They started by solving the
problem right in front of them.
They needed some specific
point to point apps.
And they created APIs
to support those apps.
But then they learned
that they could
use those same APIs
for other things,
for some of their web apps,
to drive their call centers.
And then after that, they were
able to have additional pieces
of functionality that they
could build with their APIs
like omnichannel retail, like
APIs for use by their partners.
Like even eventually, things
like digital assistance and IoT
devices.
All of these things
begin to be possible
as they started
with a simple API
and started by solving a
single business problem.
And then they branched out to
build a much more comprehensive
platform, where today, they
have a wide variety of APIs
and a wide variety of
business processes.
And this has really
enabled them to speed up
the ways in which their
customers and their own product
managers can create new things.
And we're seeing this
example across a whole lot
of industries,
where companies that
used to take months to
bring a new partner on board
or create a new
marketing campaign
are able to do this sort
of thing in days or weeks,
because once you have the
API, and once you have
the technology to make
it possible for people
to consume it via
self-service, the cost
to get a new consumer on
that API is extremely low.
Before you had APIs and
before you had self-service,
it was a totally
different world.
When you have to build
a completely new service
or a new business or hire
software developers in order
to implement a new idea, it's
much, much, much more expensive
than when someone
can simply sign up
for an API via
self-service using
an interface that a
developer understands well
and start working on.
So what we find is
that the customers that
succeed with APIs end up
sort of moving up this chain
from the left to the right.
People often start out with
APIs to solve point to point
problems, and that's fine.
We need to integrate system
A and system B. Let's
do it with an API.
So maybe once that
integration is built,
we can use it in other ways.
Or we need to build a
new mobile application.
Let's build an API for
that mobile application,
but let's make it
reusable enough
that we'll be able to use
it for other applications
in the future.
And that's where we start
to move up to the right.
We move from basically
giving access to APIs
to creating those differential
digital experiences
like the Pizza
Hut pizza tracker.
But where the real
interesting stuff comes
is when people are able to
use those APIs to create
ecosystems, to create
new types of business,
and to enter in
new ways for people
to interact with
them as companies.
So there are a couple
of different reasons
why you might want
to have an ecosystem.
One is simply you may be able
to unlock new lines of business.
Going back, I'm not sure exactly
what lines of business Pizza
Hut did, but if I look for
instance at what we talked
about with Change Health Care--
they created a
whole new business
around offering API-related
services for health care
providers to use.
Those ecosystems also
help you better meet
the needs of the customers.
And that's a really
important thing.
And they help you
discover new customers.
Those are really important,
because once you've
started to use an API
to build an ecosystem,
you may find that some
of the best customer
experiences and some of the best
new lines of business for you
could come from people
who are using your APIs
from outside your company.
We've talked for years about
API some being something
that you use to drive
third party innovation,
and that remains true.
And we have a
number of customers
who are doing that
and doing that
in some very interesting ways.
One great example of this
area is Ticketmaster.
Ticketmaster is
primarily US, but I
know they have an
international presence.
And they are very successful
at selling tickets
to online events--
well, real events.
Now maybe at this
particular moment,
there aren't as many of those
selling as there once were,
but that will come back.
And what Ticketmaster
did is they created
an API and this has
now enabled places
like retailers like
Costco, digital platforms
like Facebook--
you can even imagine an
airline or a hotel company
saying, hey, when you
book tickets at our hotel,
you might also
want to get tickets
to our local plays
using Ticketmaster.
And because they have
those APIs for business
to business interaction,
they're actually
able to create a
whole new business
channels to enable them to
be embedded in someone else's
digital experience.
And a great example of
that is that in 2018,
15% of their ticket sales
were coming this way.
So they've really seen
that by creating those APIs
and creating a platform
or an ecosystem, now
third parties can do innovative
things with the services
that they already offer.
Now a key to making
all this work
is what we call an
API product, which
is basically to say that these
APIs are not just technology.
An API is not simply a
list of your URLs and verbs
and OAuth tokens and TLS
requirements and rate limits
and JSON.
That's the technology
behind the API.
But when you build
an API, you're
creating it for somebody.
You're creating
it for a developer
who's going to build an app.
So you have to think about all
the different aspects of that.
How are you going to secure
that so that the right security
mechanism is used that for one,
your developers can actually
understand, but then
meets the security
requirements for the kind
of data that's in your API?
You've got to think
about how you're
going to monitor and
analyze it, so you
can tell whether people are
using the API effectively,
whether it's bringing
business value,
whether developers
are being successful.
You might even think about
monetizing your API, which
is you might find cases
where it makes sense
to charge for an API.
That's not something
that often comes up,
but there are a
number of companies
who have APIs that
provide businesses
where literally, on a
transactional basis,
they're worth a lot of money.
They provide very detailed
financial projections,
for instance.
That's a great example for
monetizing an API directly.
We find other cases
like Ticketmaster,
where it may actually not make
sense to monetize your API,
because it's driving
more business to you.
Or you might even want to pursue
a profit sharing philosophy,
where people who are using your
API to drive business to you
might actually take a
share of your profits.
We've seen people do all these
kinds of things with APIs,
but the key to it is to enable
self-service for developers.
That's really what APIs and
API management are all about.
It's not that difficult to
put the technology in place
to make it possible
to call something
in your business over
HTTP, send it some JSON,
and get a result back.
But now if you want
tens or hundreds
or hundreds of
thousands of developers
to use that API, either
inside your company
or outside your
company, you've really
got to think about how they're
going to learn about it,
how they're going
to get access to it,
and how they can do
this via self-service.
If using your API requires
going to a meeting
or attending a
conference call, it's
a lot less interesting
than if it's something
you can do right there in your
web browser on your computer.
OK, now we talked about
some examples of using APIs.
We've talked a
little bit about APIs
as products and the
importance of self-service.
Let's talk about how we do this
and how APIs and API management
actually fit in an organization.
So within an organization,
APIs can be everywhere.
They can be in legacy systems.
They can come from SaaS vendors.
They can be third party API.
Increasingly, we see
more and more people
having third party
services coming over
the internet that
are part of the APIs
they're delivering, even
inside a corporate network
or internal applications.
Of course, we have VMs,
we have legacy systems,
we have serverless platforms,
we have Kubernetes.
We have all kinds of technology.
But one thing that's
becoming increasingly
clear in all sizes
of an organization
is all those bits of technology
can be used to deliver APIs.
And APIs can sit on all of them
and they can talk to each other
and clients can talk to them and
all kinds of things can happen.
And the more and more
APIs an organization has,
the more important it is to
be able to keep track of them,
to have some sort of
governance over them
so that a product manager
or even a security person
can ask her questions
like, what APIs do we have?
How effectively are
they being reused?
Are they secured in
the appropriate way?
Which ones are the most popular?
How many APIs do we have
that nobody is using?
These are the kinds of
things that people bring
in API management platform in
for, because by registering
APIs with the API
management platform,
and getting statistics and
analytics from that platform,
it's actually possible to
answer some of these questions.
And many organizations
find out they have
APIs they didn't know about.
Or they have APIs that
they do know about,
but aren't being
used effectively.
And this is a big important
step for customers and companies
that are using APIs
internally to drive
all sorts of innovation.
Of course, once we
start to drive the APIs
outside the organization, it
gets even more interesting,
because now we not only have to
deal with what happens inside,
but what happens outside adds
a few new layers of complexity.
For instance, the
developer is using
the API are not necessarily
part of your organization.
So you need to
figure out how you're
going to secure that
API for their use.
Do they work with an
existing Identity Platform
or do you create a
new one just for them?
If developers are going to
use an API via self-service,
they might be using some sort
of developer portal or website
where they can learn about
APIs and sign up for access.
How do you secure that?
How do you maintain
identity there?
How do you make sure your API
documentation is effective
and your API designs are
effectively communicated?
So whereas internally, API
management and governance
tends to be about things like
enforcing API design standards,
enforcing API
security standards,
and keeping track
of what's going on,
API management outside
the organization
now includes things like
how do I market the API?
How do I make the API easy
for developers to consume?
How do I add additional
levels of security?
So for instance,
in a lot of cases,
people who have APIs on the
internet that don't require
security credentials to use like
some retail APIs that let you
get prices and store
locations, many of those
are subject to attacks by bots.
And these are not banks that
are doing a denial of service
or trying to hack your system.
These are people who have
signed up for your API
like legitimate
users, but they're
using it to scrape data for
their own competitive purposes.
So for instance, in
the travel industry,
let's try to book a hotel
room at all the hotels
and see what price they can
the competition is offering.
There are a lot of different
and interesting kind of security
threats and other things
that a company has
to take into consideration
when they offer
APIs outside the organization.
And one of the roles of
an API management system
is to help you manage those
sorts of things, as well.
So now we're not only helping
you govern and maintain
standards inside
the organization,
we're also helping
you effectively
make sure those APIs
are used, are used well,
and are used in a
secure way by people who
are outside your organization.
And once you share APIs
outside an organization,
that's when all
of the fun things
we talked about before like
governance and the ability
to create an ecosystem
and the ability
to enable third party innovation
really comes into play,
and where you can really
do some interesting things
as an organization.
Now if we jump back inside
for one more second--
I don't always
like to leave this
without talking a little
bit about the role
of internal services and
especially micro services.
There has been a lot
of cases recently where
people have started to
use APIs internally,
and then some of the
organizations that
are getting a little
bit more advanced
have been talking for the last
few years about micro services.
About breaking individual
bits of functionality
into many, many smaller
bits that are then
deployed separately that may
run on different technology
platforms.
That may be programmed
in different languages,
but which communicate most
often using API technology,
using HTTP and JSON.
Or perhaps using something
like ReQL, or GRPC.
All of these things
counts as APIs.
And all of this
micro services stuff
is a really important
step in the evolution
of businesses to
become more agile
and to do things more quickly.
But you don't want to
end up in a situation
where, as we show
here, we actually
have a lot of micro services
that talk to each other,
but we have a number of
ones that we outlined
in red, which are actually
the micro services that
talk to other micro services.
And what we often find is that
when an organization is doing
micro services
development at scale,
a particular team really
delivers an API or a few APIs.
And that API is made
visible to other teams.
That team might
choose to implement
that API on top of a
Java app server or they
may choose to implement
it on a mainframe.
Or they might choose
it to implement
with five microservices or
10 micro services or 100
micro services.
But for that team, to expose all
hundreds of those microservices
as they are directly to all
the other teams in the company
is a recipe for
disaster and chaos.
So what we often find, a
pattern that works very well,
is to create APIs facades for
those groups as micro services.
Expose that API to the other
parts of the organization.
And then what's underneath
the API can change.
It might be that
monolithic Java app today
and it might be 100 applications
using GRPC and GoLang tomorrow.
But the interface
for that service
in that team to the rest of the
organization doesn't change.
That becomes a real
important principle
that companies can
use as they start
to explore some of the
new and more agile ways
to use APIs and micro
services, technology.
And finally, I want
to talk about Google
and some of our offerings.
We've been working
hard for a long time
to offer a wide variety of
products in the API and API
management space.
On one side of the
slide, we see Apigee.
Apigee is the API
management product
we've offered for
a few years now.
I've been working
on Apigee since 2007
and it's been part of
Google Cloud since 2016.
We have a new product as
well called API Gateway.
It's a fully
managed API gateway.
And in its current
form, it's especially
well-suited for turning
serverless workloads
like that forest
of micro services
we just saw into
a coherent APIs.
And we find that in many
cases, people will really
want to take advantage
of this API gateway,
because it's small, it's
fast, it's easy to consume,
and it's fully native
and fully managed
as part of Google Cloud.
Apigee has many of
those attributes,
but Apigee is also capable of
full lifecycle API management,
managing everything in your
API program from the definition
of APIs to publishing
on developer portals
to monetization and
advanced analytics.
And over time, you'll see
us adding more capabilities
to both of these
products in order
to give it a really
good set of capabilities
so that our customers with
wide varieties of API needs
can find the right
solution in Google Cloud.
So finally, thank you.
Thank you on behalf of everyone
at Google Cloud for joining me
today.
And may you have some really
awesome digital journeys
in the future.